in today's challenge episode we'll try
and reverse a ping pong rally play on
the world's smallest table and more
let's get into it welcome to the ping
pong squash Center game to three points
let's
play you got to
[Applause]
run I
tried
[Music]
nice no how did I miss that the easiest
one easiest one you missed okay the
smash racket tic tac
toe oh oh oh the black
one oh it's a
red oh thank you thank you very
much thank
you no I made it even worse for myself
now I can
choose no oh thank you we're just
helping each other
here okay that's
mine yes that's the first step of the
great comeback I can choose whichever as
long as it's red then I
win no no
no two touches is
[Music]
enough you won it congrats we have
several fun little obstacles in this
playground
coming come
on I can't even see I'm like super d
everything is spinning look like you're
880 years
old thank you I'm still
spinning okay this is how you get it to
stick wherever you want literally
perfect on a
stick
W how do they allow these things in
playground
you need a cushion but actually all we
needed for this challenge was the pin
kit so if you have ever wanted to try
some of the things we do on our videos
but you don't know where to start many
of them only need two smash rackets a
pkin theet and some balls which happen
to have a great discount right now so
it's perfect time to get yours no no
no I'm out the new
M okay you can take it to now
[Music]
no that was a very fun challenge when it
worked and I'm like in in some very
weird pain as well next challenge is to
play a rally that looks realistic when
reversed okay let's let's try and
reverse that and see what we are working
with Amil you need to throw the ball
into one of our rackets
you have to like pull it back and hit on
your own side right
yeah yeah so that's the start from the B
you have to be like
that we have to hit it like down
[Applause]
no
why is that like that's so freaky what
you what did you try to do even like
that looks so weird the swing should be
slower and the hit should be
faster we have to do the sounds
backwards
[Music]
also
maybe we got it this is the best we can
do this is the final
[Laughter]
product where did the ball come
[Applause]
from the jaw was the best part of it was
a
jaw actually work so next challenge we
have tables that get smaller and smaller
and each table has a different challenge
I've prepared the tiniest tables in the
world first challenge for the first
table three lucky shots in a
row yeah
yeah was it was it well done you cleared
the first level onto the next table
level we've already half in size the
challenge is three Around the Net shots
in a
row oh
oh it's too
good that was a roll the next challenge
and the next table I've spent all
yesterday building these miniature
tables the design is beautiful like I
would buy these miniature tables but we
have to see if we can play on it first
you just have to get 10
shots this is really hard
yeah the smash rocket could be better
for this a bit
slower smash
rocket oh it's better you're allowed to
put the table wherever you feel
here yeah nice Definitely found a way to
cheat this
one revealing the daugh table even
smaller this is like half the size we
have custom
balls but this one is it's enough if you
just get a
rally you get a rally of two so high
temper
oh
okay bll went under the table no he went
to the let's go so annoying to pick up
who made this a
table who is
it that was three that was three so we
did it you guys
are you guys are so good it was the
craziest rally ever it just kept going I
think they're ready for the next level
can it be even smaller than
this it's
one4 before we get to the final level
can we reach 10,000 comments on this
video leave your best challenge ideas in
the comments below and we'll read them
and try to get the best ones in the next
video on to the final level
just a normal sh to broke the table the
first one to even hit the table
win first try what a shot that was a
fantastic
challenge how are we going to play from
here don't worry about it we just test
it first oh no stop stop stop oh my
God
and that was it I'm not going in there